Joe Biden's favorite Washington Post
columnist thinks it's time to take the
car keys away from Grandpa David
Ignatius writing in op-ed quote
President Biden should not run again in
2024. he argues Biden is way too old to
win and voters aren't going to roll the
dice with President Kamala
this was not an easy column to write I
haven't been anywhere in conversations
with Democrats people who follow
politics where this has not been an
issue that's been something that absorbs
people fills whole dinner conversations
but it hasn't been discussed in public
and I thought it was appropriate that
that discussion began we're running out
of time for there to be a meaningful
process of looking at alternative
candidates in a month or two it'll be
done so I think this is the time to have
that conversation and I I hope that the
Democrats will will join in this clearly
MSNBC hasn't paid their electric bills
and Morning Joe is revealing how
Democrats are all thinking the same
thing about Biden but are too afraid to
tell voters the truth
everybody we talk to every political
discussion all uh it talks a lot about
Trump but when it comes to Joe Biden
people say man he's too old to run isn't
he I mean he's not gonna he's not really
gonna every disc when I say every
discussion I don't mean 99 of the
discussions every discussion we got it I
asked Reverend Al he was hearing it all
the time on our show this past week he's
hearing it as well all right uh Jesse do
you think uh that Joe Biden will die of
embarrassment from this light
he's definitely embarrassed and because
he probably
cares what people like Ignatius think
but Ignatius to me seems like an
intelligence operative I agree so
Ignatius was the one that got the Flint
leak that bounced Flynn Ignatius is the
guy that said Chris Steele's a truth
teller he's the guy that said the laptop
was Russia disinformation when American
intelligence wants to get something out
they feed it to Ignatius so the fact
that the American intelligence Community
wants him to say this and is nudging Joe
Biden out of the picture tells me
they're worried about the impeachment
hearing because in the impeachment all
of the evidence is going to come out
the American intelligence committee is
compromised by the Biden corruption they
knew everything that was going on they
covered it up I'm talking about CIA and
FBI they don't want that out there they
don't want offshores they don't want the
Ukraine bribe uh spotlighted there's a
lot out there that need to contain and
it's not like he even said he wanted
Kamala he's like get the whole ticket
gone oh man Tulsi I hate to say this but
he actually spoke truth yes I mean no I
was as I heard that I go like this feels
like an intelligence operation and next
you're probably going to hear it from
NBC you're getting and you've got MSNBC
they're all state run what do you make
of this
um I also think Jesse is telling the
truth I mean let's let's be real here
you know way back in whatever 2019 2020
uh President Biden was not the Democrats
first pick yeah it's not who they wanted
they wanted Kamala Harris she was the
one who was supposed to be anointed
um President Biden is going to blow it
so this is this is whether it's Ignatius
and all these other people this is the
Democrat Elite and their Partners in the
mainstream media who are focused on
power they are concerned that Biden's
going to lose the election and it's
going to negatively affect them and uh
if he is not the vehicle is increasingly
it seems like he is not then they are
going to find someone else to step in uh
who will be compliant who will continue
to push their same policies or open
border policies or divisive policies
their anti-freedom policies they're War
Monger they're warmongering policies and
and again give the American people no
choice the other thing I think that's
interesting is in the article they keep
saying well there's no credible primary
Challenger to Joe Biden well at the same
time the DNC is doing everything they
possibly can to block RFK Junior exactly
to make it so anyone who dares to vote
for him their vote definitely will not
count and make it impossible they won't
even allow them to come and talk to the
DNC Rules meeting and say hey guys I got
something to say here and if he goes
independent they're going to lose yeah
and he could win Dana have you ever
heard the phrase the cat's on the roof
no it's like you know when you're a
child your cat's dead and you come home
and you go Mom Dad where's the cat
instead of telling you the cat's dead
it's on the roof
cat on the roof the cat might be on the
roof yes I was I was wondering where
that was going the cat might be on the
roof but it's interesting is that now
you might have the Biden campaign
claiming that there's government
interference in an election because if
that were to be true but I also think
that David Ignatius is just saying what
everybody is saying privately even
Morning Joe admitted that today and also
an important line in the David Ignatius
piece is that Biden's age isn't just a
Fox News Trope it's been the subject of
dinner table conversations Across
America this summer because the White
House they what they do is they think
that anything that Fox News says is a
Tailwind for them to continue but now
it's like oh no actually this is all
happening but more important than even
the intelligence Community thinking that
this has to end it's that what David
Ignatius did was give a green light to
the Democratic establishment to say you
can start the drum beat and because his
family is not asking him to resign in a
graceful way and say look I've made all
these accomplishments I'm going to turn
this over and he and what David Ignatius
also said is kama's not going to win
this for you guys yeah so you better do
something but it's getting late to stand
up a national campaign and really the
only one could that could possibly do
that right now that is has an apparatus
would be Kamala Harris so they're in a
world of hurt and the cat is on the roof
the cat is on the roof judge so the drum
beat has started do you care to make a
wager with me when this will happen when
will Joe be replaced we keep talking
about if and now we realize it's when do
you do you care to make a prediction is
there a prize behind this I say uh it's
a Thanksgiving
that's good we did I said the Friday
after Thanksgiving yes that's a good
that's a good call okay you know what's
interesting about this is you know it
Joe his age has been the subject of
dinner conversations all summer they say
and they say they don't have a
conversation without talking about it it
really shows how in lockstep the
Democrat Party is how totalitarian is
everybody I mean what seven out of 10
Democrats think he's too old and yet no
one will say anything until they get the
okay from Ignatius and I think that that
is so telling in itself and the amazing
thing is Ignatius calling upon like the
inner character or the allegiance of Joe
Biden to look in this soul and figure
what's right for the country hogwash
he's incapable of doing that he's got to
be pushed out I'll tell you another
thing which may be a piece of it the
Democrat Party is all about destroying
Donald Trump it's not about our policies
are better we want that open border we
want to make sure there's no bail ever
it's like we have to destroy Trump so
this week isn't Trump up one point in
the Trump Biden you know Face-Off it's
like all of this stuff is coming
together and they're saying maybe we
can't be beat Trump with this guy Biden
and the truth is with the impeachment
and with the fact that now they've got
the okay Biden's gone he's gone and
Kamala I mean Ignatius took care of her
yeah you know and that's the end of that
a political ideal political correctness
and picking someone for identity
politics exactly we have to start a pool
okay yeah all right hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else